The greens are coming for you
rhaenera and for your children
every man standing around the painted table
urges her to plunge the realm into war
you cannot bend the knee to the hightowers
they stole your Birthright they
Siege to the red keeper send us
I swear toward the queen your cause owns
a power that has not been seen
since the days of old valyria
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is my
house of the dragon episode 10 finale trailer
video there's a whole bunch going on here A
whole bunch of Easter eggs so we'll break it
all down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos I'll
start doing more season two videos as soon as
we get through the finale next week because we
just started with the dance of the dragons like it
actually began and we're gonna start getting some
battles in episode 10 like that is the beginning
the beginning of the trailer starts with rhaenys
immediately after leaving the dragon pit on
meleys her Dragon arriving on Dragonstone to
warn rhaenyra about what just happened like she's
still wearing her armor when she's talking to her
in the math table room with Daemon like look
they are coming for you the greens are coming
and they're going to kill all of you and your
children she's also the one to tell her that her
father viserys has died the greens just usurp the
throne by naming aegon II King and expelled all of
her supporters out of court or killed them in some
cases speaking of the greens coming for them you
see Otto Hightower with the greens on Dragonstone
on the bridge which is meant to be a Big callback
to episode 2 where Daemon basically did the same
thing with him pulling his sword on them like
they were going to throw down on the middle of the
bridge you notice she's still very pregnant with
their third child with Daemon's third child who's
a girl named visenya his Valyrian steel sword
that you see him grab during the trailer is dark
sister which was previously wielded by vicenya
aegon sister wife because Daemon and rhaenyra are
so old school Targaryen that's why they're naming
their daughter visenya it seems like a lot of
scenes in the episode will take place in the map
table room at various times during the day during
their battle planning meetings and it is meant to
be the same map table from The Game of Thrones
series they just refreshed it a little bit the
same way that they did with the Valerian dagger
like it's the cat's paws dagger but they changed
it to make a little bit more accurate to real
life so that's why the Valyrian dagger on House
of the Dragon looks different from the one on the
Game of Thrones series even though it's meant to
be the exact same dagger same idea with the map
table it was built by aegon the Conqueror after
he'd visited Westeros growing up it was before he
decided to conquer the Seven Kingdoms like when
he was much younger growing up he spent a lot of
time I'm flying his Dragon blur in the black dread
around Westeros just visiting different places
around the different Realms then he had the map
table constructed then he had the dragon dream
about the long night the prophecy of A Song of
Ice and Fire that he called and then he decided
to conquer the Seven Kingdoms it wasn't like he
decided to conquer the Seven Kingdoms and then
he had the map table built when Daemon walks by
and grabs his Valyrian steel sword Dark sister
I'm not sure who this Targaryen or valerion is
in the background here it's a little too blurry to
tell who it is the thing is though is that during
the dance of the Dragons there are a bunch of
dragonseeds because the more dragons you control
the more Dragon Riders you have the more powerful
your side is they're supposed to be about 17 total
dragons during the house of the dragon series
in general during all four seasons that they'll
do and we're only going to see nine during season
one so when we're talking about Dragonseeds other
Dragon Riders popping up that gives you an idea of
how many other people we're going to meet during
future seasons Daemon urges rhaenyra not to accept
Allison's terms remember she was going to send a
raven with the greens terms she had to bend the
knee and would be allowed to keep Dragonstone and
they wouldn't kill her but she'd have to give up
any claim on the iron throne own one of the big
Ideas during the dance of the Dragons is that you
have a lot of the men around these two women like
rhaenyra and Alice and obviously the blacks and
the greens you have a lot of the men around them
on both sides telling them what to do without
getting into a lot of spoilers like there's
a ton of stuff that's going to happen during the
dance of the dragons in the next couple of Seasons
so on team black and Team Green you have a lot
of people making a lot of really bad decisions
then we see aemond taking off his eye patch
revealing the blue sapphire that sits where his
eye used to be we see it in the new intro scene
here like that's why there's a blue sapphire on
here speaking of which there are a couple other
big changes to the intro scene we see the fourth
missing child of Allison here Daeron Targaryen
we'll see him during season two George RR Martin
said they just didn't have enough time to get
to him during season one for aemond there's a
sapphire eye for his missing eye for aegon symbol
there's a naked woman wearing a crown because he
just got crowned King for Helena's symbol it's
a spider which she was embroidering during the
episode which is a reference to her Dragon dream
about the dance of the Dragons earlier and we have
the three children of aegon in Helena and they're
all represented by the six finger hands the reason
why their six finger hands is because jahiris
their grandfather the king before viserys had
six digits on his hands in his feet then we see
rhaenyra's black council meeting now remember the
title of episode 9 was the green council the title
of episode 10 is the black council so it's like
rhaenyra's version of what just happened in the
red keep with the greens each faction forms their
own version of the small council reneers is just
called the black Council I'm not sure who some of
these kingsguard are we do know that erryk with
an E the other twin brother who got away at the
end of last week's episode who was advocating
against supporting aegon winds up stealing
viserys's crown and bringing it to her so she
can Crown herself Queen but the whole idea here
and I explained this during my episode 9 video is
that the kingsguard's loyalty is divided because
of what's happened so like some of the kingsguard
side with her and come to Dragonstone but not all
of them I do know that this person here is Lord
bartimos celtigar how celtagar is just another
vassal House of House Targaryen that we haven't
seen much of this season but they're close by
too they're not quite as powerful as House of
valerian or House Targaryen obviously the symbol
of their house is a crab which will remind you of
the crab feeder earlier this season although I'm
not sure if the crab feeder was a bastard of Hal
celtegar that would have been pretty cool because
the Celtic guards do have some Valyrian blood in
their veins Lord celtigar is the one telling her
advocating for sacking King's Landing and it's
meant to be a big parallel for Daenerys sacking
King's Landing later in the timeline although not
quite the level of burned them all that Daenerys
went like rhaenyra doesn't go mad the way that
Daenerys went in the actual sacking of King's
Landing doesn't really happen till way later in
the dance of the Dragon so they'll probably save
that for like a WTF moment at the end of season
two like season two episode nine or episode 8
or something like that there's a lot of battles
that have to happen before that they plant their
figure-hair at Winterfell for all those wanting
the Starks to come back into the story they become
a much bigger deal later on in the dance of the
dragons they wind up siding with rhaenyra but it's
cregen stark the son of ricken stark who was the
former Lord who bent the need to rhaenyra earlier
in episode 1 you have to remember that Rick and
Stark was already very old and that was almost
20 years ago so I think the idea is that when
the dance the dragons actually get started like
episode 10 season 2 episode 1 his son cregan stark
has already taken lordship of the house but the
big idea here is they're trying to figure out who
all their supporters are around the realm and who
they want to treat with like who should we go to
and ask for help house stark winds up being one of
those houses when Jakira says send us he's talking
about rhaenyra sending the children here jacaerys
lucerys Bala and rhaena on all their dragons to
all these different Lords of the realm to try and
treat with them and get them to support rhaenyra
so unless they made some huge changes jacaerys
winds up being the one to fly his Dragon Vermax up
to Winterfell to treat with house Stark supposedly
there's a rumor that he also fell in love with
one of the Stark girls maybe we'll see some of
that story during season two we'll see remember
though jakaris rides Vermax lucerys rides arrax
who we see for the first time in the trailer Baela
rides Moondancer and rheana rides a dragon called
morning and all four of their dragons are much
younger way way smaller than the other dragons
but they're way quicker too way more agile Eric
brings viserys's stolen crown to rhaenyra as she
crowns herself Queen of the Seven Kingdoms and
now you have two monarchs at the same time aegon
II in runera kind of like a smaller version of the
war of the five Kings there's a bunch of scenes of
lucerys having a rematch with aemond in Vegas at
Storm's end so it sounds like lucerys gets sends a
Storm's End to try and treat with the baratheons
and aemond winds up flying vhagar there to try
and stop them I don't think we've ever seen the
exterior of Storm's End in this way we saw the
main chamber earlier this season in on house the
dragon just because you know totally different
show different part of the timeline they tried
to feature different houses in different places
that they didn't feature that much during the Game
of Thrones series currently during the events of
episode 10 the stormlands are still being ruled
by Boremund Baratheon same person as before he
started as a rhaenyra supporter but his oldest
son the next Lord actually supports the green
so it's a big problem with their house where their
allegiance lies obviously the big deal here though
is lucerys versus aemond because lucerys if he
actually got into a drag out fight with aemond
wouldn't have a chance aemond himself is just
physically way bigger vhagar is massive compared
to his dragon arrax it also seems like during this
scene aemond winds up revealing his sapphire eye
to luceres like haha remember that time when we
were kids rheanyra's supporters say their cause
holds a power that hasn't been seen since the days
of old valyria that's because team black possessed
way more dragons currently at the beginning of
the dance and it's also meant to foreshadow the
big reveal of vermithor literal and metaphorical
big reveal of vermithor so vermithor was jeharis's
Dragon before this he hasn't had a writer since
jaehaerys died but he's meant to be the biggest
oldest dragon after vhagar not quite as big as
vhagar but still really really big and that's
basically what's happening in this scene here
Daemon going to the dragon caves on Dragonstone
where vermithor has been roosting to summon
him and he's singing a song in High Valyrian
it seems like Daemon is really enjoying what
just happened like yes it's gonna be crazy but
he's like oh yes we're gonna go to war or there's
going to be so much fighting I'm going to have so
much fun burning everything there's also some
parallels between what Daemon does during the
beginning of the dance of the Dragon some of
the opening battles and what aegon the conqueror
did during the conquest like I said Daemon and
rhaenyra are both old school Targaryen so they
love doing things like aegon the conqueror did
that's also one of the reasons why their newest
child is going to be named after aegon's sister
wife visenya vermithor's just been roosting on
Dragonstone ever since jaehaerys died many years
ago going riderless but he's about a hundred years
old when the episode picks up so he's had so many
writers over the years that he's actually grown a
little bit more comfortable around humans he's
still very temperamental like all dragons like
they want him to seem really scary when Daemon
goes to summon him like oh by the way we're gonna
need your help but it's really the younger dragons
that you need to watch out for that tend to be
more aggressive towards all people the final scene
of the Dragons all leaving Dragonstone are either
all the kids just leaving to treat with all the
different Lords that they decide they're going to
try and get support from during the dance of the
dragons this red one might be melees in rhaneys
though because it's a little bit bigger but the
smaller ones are probably jacarison lucerys on
vermax and arrax for those of you wondering how
they're going to end the season like they already
had a really crazy moment with rhaenys and meleys
inside the dragon pit my early prediction is that
aemond will wind up killing lucerys in revenge
like there's no way lucerys could win against
aemond and vhagar and aemond is vicious like you
saw him in the previous episodes doing all that
battle training clearly lucerys is outmatched by
him and what they might do is just have lucerys'
death be the huge WTF blow to rhaenyra at the
end of the season and then they go for their
revenge either at the beginning of season two or
they really really want to blow through the plot
in episode 10 they might also have them get their
revenge during episode 10. but like you have this
whole idea that there are several big battles that
happen during the dance of the dragon so lots of
big battles coming in season two and usually what
happens is that team black does something then
team green retaliates or vice versa and speaking
of mysaria a lot of you guys asking at the end of
episode 9 there was a random burning building at
the end of the episode with a hooded figure just
walking away after putting it to the torch I think
the idea is that was meant to be mysaria's house
being put to the torch by larys strong's men
who told Otto Hightower you could benefit from
my help because he was trying to get himself
put on the small council and made the official
master of whispers on the green Council in him
torching mysaria's house would make sense if
he's trying to take control of the Spy Network
inside the red keep which currently in mysaria
controls previously mysterious said that she would
support Otto Hightower when they were meeting but
the retaliation against her the burning of her
house would be a reason why she would turn against
them and support Daemon in the blacks but if he
spotted any of their Easter eggs or references
in the trailer footage that I didn't talk about in
the video just write them Below in the comments in
my full episode 10 video will post next week after
they release it but I do have a couple big bonus
videos planned this week too and after the finale
I will start doing more season 2 videos Everyone
click here for my full episode 9 video and click
here for all my other house of the dragon videos
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!